proteins have rather uniform common
structure we nowadays know about
chemical structure of more than 100
million proteins this is what's in the
databases and of this 100 million about
35 million protein chemical structures
are well ascertained the rest may be
questionable but this is enormous number
in spite of the fact that all these
proteins consist of the strength I'm 20
building blocks which are arranged in a
linear chain say perform widely
different functions just think of the
fact that hair and skin are made of
protein and so are enzymes in our
stomach the stomach enzymes couldn't
work if they were not dissolved in water
now imagine if the hair and the skin
protein would also dissolve in water so
you have to know more than just this
linear chemical structure and that's
what I'm studying how are these linear
chains arranged in three-dimensional
space there has been work on this
question long before we started by Chris
and this was all done by crystallography
special I mean Nobel Prize in 1962 in
chemistry was given to Max Perutz and
John Kendrew for having determined the
first three-dimensional arrangement of a
polypeptide chain now what is new in my
work is that
these pictures of proteins can be
obtained in aqueous solution aqueous
solutions are body fluids such as blood
stomach fluid saliva and similar and
though you can imagine that seeing those
molecules in the environment in which
they are active in our bodies is of some
interest and I believe that this is why
I was given a Nobel Prize
although three-dimensional structures
and crystals had earlier on been
determined